and jacob degrom
set to bid for a third consecutive cy
young season
swinging a miss he struck him out and
degrom begins the season
with an overpowering strikeout of ronald
acuna well that one what wasn't even on
the corner that was just raw power right
down the pipe belt high
and boy did he beat him here's pinch
swinging a chopper left side cutting to
his left mcneal the third baseman has it
throws to first in time
side retired mike soroka is all warmed
up and ready to go for
atlanta first opening day start for the
22 year old right-handers
rips to freddie freeman who caught it
and tagged the bag a line drive
double play thank you very much
goes back to work here's the one-two
swung
out and missed strike three bury the
slider down and in
austin riley and riley checks his swing
and he foul tips it into ramos glove
strike three
here's keno and the 1-0 coming hold on
the ground to the right side
albie's has it feet swanson for one back
to first double play
the braves have their second double play
in the first two innings
and now alex jackson looking for his
first big league hit
and degrom with the high fastball
strikes out jackson and that's four
strikeouts first time through the
batting order for jake
j.d davis is the mets left fielder he
leads off the third inning and there's
that turbo sinker boy both pitchers
really
amped up for this matchup as we'd expect
wilson ramos
the mets catcher steve right three call
painted the inside corner with a
fastball at 93 so back-to-back
strikeouts for soroka freddie freeman
leads off to fourth
oh two freeman swings and misses strike
three
jacob degrom goes to the slider to
strike out freeman
and there's one out here in the fourth
the circle change
has a little daylight between his palm
and the ball and out of nobody on now
marcelo zuna
3-2 coming on the outside corner got him
looking ozuna thought it was wide
but degrom gets the call from paul north
for his sixth strike
as jeff mcneal bats waits for the first
pitch
hammers it toward first it's fair down
the right field line it bounces all the
way to the corner acuna is after it as
mcneal heads towards second acuna's got
a good arm his throw
is in time to get mcneal they're going
to replay that
as mcneal went sliding into second
seemed like he thought he would have
that double more easily than he did but
acuna
fired a rifle and throws on mcneil
trying to stretch a single into a double
i thought he
was safe i thought the tag was laid
terrific throw
gare no question right on the money
i think he's safe yeah i think he beat
it this one didn't take long
and they do overturn the call and it's a
double for jeff mcneal who had 38
doubles last year
here's pete alonso who drove in 120 runs
last year and it grounds one to short
mcneal trying to advance
him and mcneal gets upended by the tag
on his foot from riley
he appears to be okay poor base running
decision by mcneal and he's thrown out
for the second half to go after he heats
up in the fifth inning this could be
degrom's last go round
and so he goes back to the slider and
strikes him out for the second time
at seven k's now for degrom and it'll
bring up dansby swanson
one two coming struck him out 98 away
eight strikeouts now for degrom and four
and two third
so one out and one on now jd davis
in the air center field that's well hit
ender going back
to the wall leaping try he got it
great catch by ncrt and soroka's pumped
up
[Applause]
davis thought he got it the park just
big enough to hold it
and that's the second out can you see
where there
why ender is such a valuable
piece of this team defensively the way
he plays centerfield we've seen him do
this time and time again he gets back to
the wall
finds his place times his jump perfectly
last year with the best mets pitcher not
named jacob degrom he had a phenomenal
year and he makes his debut in the sixth
inning today
stops at the belt now the pitch swung
out and missed strike three
now he flew it by him again at 95.
breaking balls fastball in to set up
that fastball cutting you're right keith
away
so one out of nobody on now ronaldo and
he goes outside to get acuna same as he
did to jackson with that fastball and
he's got back-to-back strikeouts to
start the sixth
and now marcelo zuna benz 1-1 pitch
rifle to left that's headed for the
corner and azuna is going to have an
extra base hit
davis will dig it out of the left field
corner
and the braves have their first scoring
chance there's the first atlanta extra
base hit
two out and now lugo with a chance to
get through it facing austin riley
payoff pitch again from lugo
on the inside corner strike three call
lugo burns the fastball over the inside
edge of the plate
but sith lugo works around a one-out
double here in the seven
that's for this hole for two grounded to
third as last time
and he drives one deep left field headed
back toward the wall
that ball is out of here you're in his
system
more than two years on the sidelines
he's back with a home run
and the mets lead it one-nothing in the
seventh fastball belt high
up out over the plate and he knew it
right from the get-go
justin wilson is on to pitch in the
eighth thing 2-2 pitch
playing in a miss strike three got him
with a fastball so
justin wilson punches out new hall
edwin diaz is here to close trying to
protect a one-nothing lead
got him looking two men down second time
today that ozuna has been called out on
a fastball on the outside part of the
plate
that ball came back and framed nicely
by ramos and matt adams will be the last
hope for the braves
he struck it out and the ball game is
over another
opening day success for the new york
match 39 of their last
51 on opening day diaz closes it out and
cespanus hits the dramatic home run and
his return to action